Most of your classes will
provide links to two other tools
you'll use frequently,
Piazza and Udacity.
Most of your time in the OMS program
will be spent on using these three
tools, T-Square, Udacity, and Piazza.
We also recommend bookmarking
these three tools individually.
>> That just about covers everything
there is to know about T-Square.
Note that T-Square can experience
some pretty major slow-downs,
especially around submission time for
some of your projects.
So try to submit things a little early,
just to be safe.
Check with your classes' TAs to see
if they've built in a little lag time
into the deadline to allow for
T-Square's slowness or glitches.
We'll close with one
little trick as well.
You might notice that T-Square generally
doesn't let you run multiple tabs of
T-Square in one browser,
they interfere with each other.
However, if you open up a new window and
load T-Square there,
you can run two instances of it to view
multiple assignments side by side or
use multiple tools at the same time.
So that can be a major help.
So now that we've covered T-Square,
let's move on to talking about the other
site you'll use most often, Udacity